une idée de prime time bomb ces
adorables
mais j'ai mis les
le prime time ouais ce sera on va
rediffuser bouffe
c'est pas une bonne du tout et on va le
regarder tous ensemble n en laisse et
jean fera des arrêts sur le mal et on
commentera mais généreuse en voilà des
analystes debout mais ça s'appellera
cela soit mais bon sens va pas venu ici
pour souffrir autant
ça prend ta gouverne cette porte à
gouverner quand vous avez 850 milles
séparaient ces prédateurs c'est pas une
bonne du tout a mis 150 millions
téléspectateurs
c'est vrai sociale marine parce que je
vous dise j'ai ressorti les audiences et
emménage à la loi vous taisez vous jure
sorti les audiences je vous dire après
un démarrage moyen avec 30 soit 326 me
téléspectateurs et à 24% du public le 11
avril dernier où j'avais réussi à se
maintenir en deuxième semaine avant de
perdre la moitié de son petit troisième
numéro un depuis les audiences sont
restés sous la barre des 200 minutes
en moyenne sept premières saisons du
gouffre quel chien sera
l'unique deux cent trente sept mille
fidèles chaque soir soit 1,1 du bon sens
du public 1 4 ans et plus je réfute ces
chiffres totalement chez les chiffres
voilà donc voila merci mr avait dit
touareg ont séduit les noms là on est
franchement je suis très très chaud pour
le faire je te demande aux
téléspectateurs si vous êtes chaud je
pense qu'on peut passer une soirée m'a
dit je voudrais refaire les happenings
de bouffe en mai mais rossi voilà
franchement je pense que ça peut être
génial pour tous nos chiens ramené de
personnes d'abord amènera des chiens
voilà ramener ce que vous voulez mais
juste me demandez rien d'accord produire
bah oui je préfère ça oui je vais
produire cette merde
expliquez moi est ce qu'on pourrait
peut-être de faire un petit sondage et
expliquent bien sûr d'avoir voilà est ce
que vous êtes pour cette fois réponse a
dit 'nous on sur twitter on lance tout
de suite voilà ils vont venir à vous me
proposez de réanimer mon échec en
exhalant sait pas aller chez le regarder
dans l'échappée va revoir ensemble vous
coanimera avec moi
à oui mais à voulait surfer sur le
succès
ok vous allez co animé avec moi aurait
assez gratifiant vin est ce que ça vous
dirait bonjour et au revoir
alors je vous dis la coanimation et moi
oui
les 55 55
55 ans voilà ça alors franchement je
peux m'en fais totalement je suis fait
un saut au linge pas du tout à ça près
benjamin tu me connais la vérité je vous
connais vrai c'est impossible de
connaître
ses valeurs at il est de retour les
normes et tutu s'en sortir je parlais
s'il te plaît non non c'est impossible
avec vous un bon son plein de raisons
d'ailleurs on va essayer oui très bien
qu'on va essayer on coanimera sens
j'aimerais bien essayer quand même ah
oui ouais bah p our n'ont pas trouvé d
échec
[Rires]
enfin
en
cherchant bien on trouve des chocs pour
l'échec de chacun sera pas mal
vous savez que c'est vrai ça serait pas
mal mais moi je refuse ce cover à mai
mois
minimum à 108 103 bah oui ça se termine
mais ça n'est pas un échec mais bon
quand même un rapport à août
alors s'il vous plaît siaka
moussaoui que jamais pensé je savais que
les pompes à avoir comme invité didier
roi ouf
malade tu ferais bien là bravo
mademoiselle même à la voir bon alors on
est d'accord sur ça on va faire et j'ai
envie qu'on passe une pêche hongrie
venir s'inviter au gabon
refaire vidéo gag sas a toujours là on
l'a fait on fait vidéo gage c'est à dire
que si on regarde des vidéos qui sont
vraiment trop pourri on doit vraiment un
gars l'âge c'est fait c'est bon tu sais
c'est
bon les mecs de james bond demain ne
meurt jamais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous speed avec le canada aurait volé
ouais amène book et des aubergines
dans le camion et a pris un coup qui
dérivent camin huawei l'armée la sépaq
et qui est annoncée à arrêter il est
très beau et du ritz était au bord de la
route
voilà franchement vous ça vous fait
génération mannequin bassirou la
génération mannequin on leur fait avait
très bien voilà et bien dans le jury
examine ce matin les yeux pleins les
yeux
[Applaudissements]
vous savez que taux plein les yeux on
cartonne aussi mais les mecs je vous
jure on va faire à chaque personne son
prime ouais je ferai ça à partir de
janvier assez génial bien ça la chaîne
est d'accord vous voulez que
c est le patron peut dire quand je mets
pas du tout patron c'est maintenant
l'exemple voulez vous appelle je
voudrais
pas que j'appelle francs capitaux le
préfet la chaîne si vous voulez je
l'appelle mais je vais lui demander
après mais déjà qu'ils réfléchissent
mais moi je trouve que la mm100 ribéry
et antoine et suivront tient avec l'idée
aux gags bouffe
génération mannequin c'est devenu maire
jamais de manoeuvre jamais on fait un
truc quoi la serbie 2 1 louis l'un et
ouvre sa plateforme déjà mannequin et
bouffe c'est fort dès lors qu'il achète
une partie du comité exécutif
lui a pété un câble il est parti en tête
totalement moi aussi j'ai un truc je
viens faire ou en tant que candidat
c'est vrai j'ai plein de
chiens
[Rires]
voulait faire
lors des chiens d'ailleurs je vous le
dis et je vous le dis à l'offre alors
mais je vous dis la vérité passe lui de
très mauvais des coffrets je vous le dis
et ça ça joue pas pour vous sur ce que
j'ai essayé de faire prier il s'était
dit non mais je vous dis il ya plein de
jeunes filles faciles mais franchement
guillaume genton je ne peux pas ces
chiens les chez lui tout ça je ne
connais je vous le jure je vous le dis
comme je le pense sincèrement c'est vrai
mais j'en ai dit si tu en as combien de
temps vous les connaissez chien mais je
les ai vu en photo s'est passé pas plus
à des chiens non mais c'est pas des
chiens ils y auraient ils sont très
sympas mais il va être tranquillement
avec une jeune fille en train de boire
en train de siroter un papa nous les v
ya le chien des bougies sur la chaussure
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est au riz et tranquillement
au bord de la piscine talent un chien
qui te chie sur la tombe non mais c'est
vrai que quand je serai comme mal à
dormir dans des chambres qui sont
manifestés contre elle me donne rendez
vous en rendez vous ça que je vais
locales ont rendez vous galant calmez
vous avec les chiens maintenant je lis
pas ce qu'ils peuvent faire peur